The satirical horror movie Velvet Buzzsaw
explores what happens when the pretentious
world of modern art collides with a collection
of supernaturally-charged paintings from a
dead artist with a dark and horrific past.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in
this video I'm explaining everything you need
to know about Velvet Buzzsaw, the movie's
ending and what each of the kills represents.
Plus I'll be delving into who Vetril Dease
really is and how his supernatural art comes
to life.
As you'd expect, spoilers ahead for the movie,
so take care if you haven't seen it yet.
When ambitious assistant Josephina stumbles
across the dark, creepy art of dead painter
Vetril Dease, her decision to commercialise
the work that the painter wanted to destroy
kicks off a series of escalating horrific
deaths.
As Josephina looks at one of his portraits,
the ashes of paintings that Dease was burning
before he died, re-ignite, the first indication
of the supernatural forces inside his art.
The eyes on this portrait also seem to shift
slightly from the centre to the side looking
at Josephina as she unravels and examines
more paintings inside the dead artist's apartment.
Those watching eyes are a spine-chilling premonition
of what's to come for many of the characters
in the movie.
Eyes often show up shortly before a character
dies, as if they're observing and making a
moral judgement.
Just after gallery owner Rhodora reveals to
Josephina that she's deliberately removing
many of Dease's works from the market in order
to create scarcity and drive up the value,
the eyes on a wall watch Bryson who's been
tasked with hiding the art and who opens up
a crate removing some of the paintings presumably
to keep for himself.
Bryson, of course, ends up dead shortly after
at the hands of some painted monkey mechanics.
Just before Gretchen's deadly encounter with
the sphere, the blurred eyes of the boy and
girl in this portrait come into focus.
It's as if Dease's spirit is awakening in
the painting and is about to pass deadly judgement
on Gretchen for how she's abandoned the principles
of her former position as a museum curator
to make money and deliberately gain special
access and favours for private clients.
Likewise, the eyes in a sinister doll open
up to watch gallery owner Jon just before
he's strangled by an installation in his gallery.
And after Josephina ditches Damrish when he
decides to go back to his art collective,
there's an especially creepy eye on the graffitied
wall behind her looking right at her.
The mural comes alive setting a spectacular
trap for her as a gallery full of graffiti
art opens up behind the wall.
Josephina's death seems particularly appropriate
as the paint from the art that she so despises
melts, runs towards her and then consumes
her.
And, after she's killed we see she's been
incorporated directly into the graffitied
wall.
What's going on with each death is that each
victim ends up becoming part of the deadly
artwork.
Bryson was pulled into the painting of the
monkey mechanics, and the sphere consumed
Gretchen's arm and her dead body was assumed
by most people to be just another part of
the art installation.
Remember that the archivist who was studying
Dease's paintings for Rhodora discovered there
was blood tissue in every one of the works
she studied.
She assumed the blood belonged to Dease, and
that seems quite plausible because in one
of the flashbacks, there's a bowl full of
blood with a bloodied knife and razor next
to it, and we also see a glimpse of Dease
painting with a hand partially wrapped in
a bandage of sorts and what looks like cuts
or wounds around his wrists.
Writer-director Dan Gilroy has talked about
how one of the themes of Velvet Buzzsaw is
"the idea that artists invest their spirit
into their art."
It seems as if by literally painting his own
flesh and blood into his works, Dease has
invested them with a supernatural spirit.
While the characters in the film are all desperately
trying to take advantage of Dease's artwork
and exploit his life and everything he lived
through for their own gain, what they don't
realise, as Daveed Diggs, who plays Damrish,
has said, "is that Dease's past and the violence
he lived will actually reach out and kill
you."
If new victims like Josephina and Bryson end
up becoming part of the art which killed them,
then perhaps it's also possible that some
of Dease's paintings contain blood tissue
from his previous victims.
For example we learn in the movie that as
an adult Dease tracked his abusive father,
tortured him and burned him alive, but what
if Dease painted parts of his father into
some of his paintings as well?
Now, we need to talk about Rhodora and the
importance of her tattoo "Velvet Buzzsaw"
which carries a lot of meaning especially
as it's also the movie's title.
First of all, it's the name of the punk rock
duo Rhodora formed with her friend Polly Anna.
Damrish tells Rhodora he was a fan of their
early work, but the pair eventually split
up.
What matters though is that Rhodora abandoned
her original passion and anarchic roots and
decided instead to become part of the status
quo, building a career as a well-known dealer
in the moneyed and powerful world of art.
As she's built her status in the art world,
Rhodora's learned how to trick and manipulate
artists, buyers and rivals alike.
She understands how to pick up promising new
talent like Damrish for her gallery while
simultaneously offloading talent like Piers
who's no longer productive onto her rival
Dondon.
Rhodora also manoeuvres Josephina into partnering
with her to sell the stolen Dease paintings,
and in the past she's manipulated Morf behind
his back by using his boyfriend for inside
information.
Her smarts almost seem to get her through
to the end of the film unscathed as she realises
just how dangerous Dease's paintings really
are and she empties her house of any art or
images.
However, Dease's spirit still finds a way
to enact revenge on her for stealing his work,
and the "Velvet Buzzsaw" tattoo on her neck
springs to life slicing her to death while
she's in a pose which mirrors the art previously
on her bedroom wall.
Ultimately, as Rhodora herself said, "art
is always dangerous"; and the "no death, no
art" tattoo on her arm is, of course, particularly
fitting for both her and the movie.
The name "Velvet Buzzsaw" is also an interesting
oxymoron as it implies something soft and
luxurious but sharp and deadly at the same
time.
It applies to Rhodora and how she softly,
softly manipulates people around her while
also using more cutting methods to get what
she wants, for example, threats of legal action
to force Josephina into sharing ownership
of Dease's art; and remember that Damrish
says he was specifically warned to be careful
of Rhodora.
The name Velvet Buzzsaw also applies to the
lethal threat that a seemingly innocent piece
of art can pose.
Velvet Buzzsaw is clearly a pointed critique
of the contemporary art world and the pretentious
critic Morf certainly isn't spared as he ends
up dead at the hands of Hobo Man, the walking,
talking homeless superhero that Morf was so
willing to critically tear apart at the beginning
of the movie.
I wonder whether the inclusion of this particular
artwork of a down-on-his-luck, former superhero
is not only a comment on the changing nature
of what's popular or in when it comes to the
art world, but also a reference to how one
of the most popular genres in current film
and TV entertainment, the superhero franchise,
will eventually, like other genres before
it, fall out of the great favour it's currently
in.
Gilroy also appears to think that critics
can be too fast to point out faults and criticise
the work an artist may have poured their heart
and soul into.
There's also some interesting commentary on
whether too much value is given to the opinion
of a critic.
In the film, Rhodora says Morf "is a god"
in their world, and when he decides to publish
his negative review of Hobo Man, it kills
the sale of the piece that was brokered before
the review ran.
Morf is occasionally presented a little more
positively than some of the other characters,
such as when he turns down Gretchen's proposal
to feed her early information about his reviews.
However, he demonstrates he's more than willing
to sacrifice any principles he may have if
it's expedient for him to do so or to cater
to his own prejudices.
For example, he gives a negative review to
Ricky's art show even though he liked it,
because he was sleeping with Josephina at
the time and she asked him to make her ex-boyfriend
Ricky suffer.
And when Morf discovers Damrish is sleeping
with Josephina, he yells "The admiration I
had for your work has completely evaporated!"
He's also ridiculously fussy and snobbish,
complaining about cheesy funeral music; and
although he warns Rhodora that Dease's work
is dangerous and to "stop selling it, box
it up and get rid of it", we see that he's
kept some of it for himself and is going to
lock it away in storage, presumably to sell
on in the future for a huge profit.
That moment is, of course, his ultimate undoing
because that's when he comes face to face
with Hobo Man who he disparaged so savagely
at the beginning of the film.
Ultimately then, the characters who die in
Velvet Buzzsaw receive a death that parallels
how they've behaved.
Morf is literally torn apart by the thing
which he figuratively tore to shreds earlier,
and as the movie's producer Jennifer Fox says,
Josephina "is consumed by the graffiti art
she rejected and Rhodora by selling out her
punk roots […] Bryson is killed by acting
on his primitive nature [and] Gretchen for
over reaching."
So, why are some characters not targeted by
Dease's supernatural creations and survive
to the end of the movie?
It seems that Gilroy may view Coco, Damrish
and Piers as relatively innocent in comparison
to the others and therefore perhaps worthy
of being spared the wrath of Dease.
Coco, played by Natalia Dyer who many of you'll
know from Stranger Things, is too new to the
art scene to have been completely corrupted.
As an outsider who's only just joining that
world, she's still clear-headed enough to
understand what isn't art.
For example, after Gretchen bleeds to death
from having her arm sliced off by the Sphere,
Coco's the only person who can recognise that
a dead body sprawled on the floor isn't actually
a piece of art.
As artists themselves, John Malkovich's Piers
and Daveed Diggs's Damrish seem to understand
the underlying power of Dease's art.
Piers and Damrish both become mesmerised by
Dease's paintings and this seems to be the
trigger that leads Damrish to abandon Rhodora's
gallery and go back to his Collective, much
to Josephina's disgust.
Piers also goes back to creating art purely
for himself, making sand drawings that the
tide gradually washes away as the credits
roll.
Interestingly enough, that scene was inspired
by Dan Gilroy's own experiences in the 1990s
writing the movie Superman Lives, starring
Nic Cage and directed by Tim Burton.
When he found out the movie was being canned
after 18 months of work, Gilroy told EW that
he went down to the beach and thought about
how nothing he wrote was ever going to be
seen and so he "might as well come down and
write words in the sand and have the waves
just wash them away."
But that was also the day that Gilroy decided
to value what he creates not for how many
people see it or its commercial success, but
simply for himself.
However you feel about the movie, Velvet Buzzsaw
is more than just a horror film set in the
contemporary art world.
It's also a commentary about our relationship
with any art form, including movies and TV.
Velvet Buzzsaw's producer Fox has said it's
"about the commodification of art […] and
the way in which this self-selecting group
of curators and dealers […] is anointing
certain people, ignoring other people, and
[...] creating a false economy."
Gilroy has also said "art can't really exist
without somebody paying for it, but once art
becomes monetized, it loses something.
[And] the problem when you over-monetize 'Art,'
it becomes an object rather than something
imbued with a spirit, or an idea, or even
a soul."
Which is why there's that line in the movie
where Josephina says "what's the point of
art if nobody sees it?"
The film itself suggests that it's only the
artists who realise the true value of art,
as both Damrish and Piers reject the over-commoditised
art scene and return to their artistic roots.
This whole idea of the point of art and who
sees it is also interesting because although
Velvet Buzzsaw premiered at the Utah-based
indie film festival Sundance, the movie is
available on the global streaming service
Netflix, which means a lot more people will
likely see this film than if it were only
released in cinemas.
As for writer-director Dan Gilroy, he has
various ambitions for the film: obviously,
he wants people to see and enjoy the movie,
but he also wants it to spark conversations
and ideas.
On top of that, he told Vanity Fair that he
hopes "people look at art in a slightly different
way. [... and that they] realize the artists
have invested [...] their creative soul into
the work."
And finally, he'd like the movie "to do for
the art world what Jaws did for swimming."
In other words, "When walking into a gallery
of art, one should fear what might happen..."
After all, what about all those Dease paintings
that have found their way into the hands of
street vendors selling them for five bucks
a piece?
Will Dease be ok with this as the works are
in the hands of the people now rather than
in the privileged art scene?
Or will he move on from taking revenge on
the hypocritical art world to judging the
everyday hypocrisy of ordinary people?
So, what do you think of Velvet Buzzsaw?
And what did you take away from the movie?
Let me know in the comments below.
If you're new here and enjoyed this, then
every week I have new movie breakdowns, so
do subscribe and hit the bell to get all my
new videos.
Until then, you can tap left for my latest
horror movie video or tap right for another
video you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see ya next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!